Let's say that initially, you've got through,
two memory locations, a and b, and both
these memory locations have been initialized to
zero. And let's say that there are two
processes executing on two different processes, P1 and P2, and so a and b, c
and d, they're all shared memory locations.
And let's say that process P1 is executing
this piece of code. It's assigning a + 1 to a, b + 1 to b and there is another
process P2 that is using the values b and a and assigning them
to variables d and c. Now one thing you have to recognize is that the process
of P1 and process of P2 are working
completely independently, right? They're completely independent of each other.
It is just that these memory locations a, b, c, and d are all shared memory
locations. And, but, we have no way of
knowing the relative ordering of all of these instructions
that we're seeing here. When you think about
a uniprocessor program there is an expectation that instructions
are textually the way they're ordered, is the
order in which the processor is executing. But what
we're looking at is instructions that are happening on
different processes. There's a set of instructions here. Set
of instructions here. All manipulating the same shared memory.
So the question to you is what possible values
do you expect to see for d and c? Do you expect that, when, let's say that you
know, process P1 completes, process P2 completes. We don't
know what order they executed. Both have completed executions.
At the end of that, would you expect to see c and d to be equal to 0,
c and d to be both equal to 1, c to be equal to 1 and d to be equal to
0, c to be equal to be 0 and d to be equal to 1, okay? Basically I've given
you all the permutation combinations of the four possibilities for
the values that c and d can assume. Given this
set of instructions that is happening, partially on P1, partially on P2.